[Music]
well I went to see Annie on Broadway
when I was five or six years old and I
saw the girls on stage singing and and
and acting performing and I knew that's
what I wanted to do so I started going
to summer theater camp and doing plays
at school
and then I started doing some
commercials in in elementary school and
go to these huge casting calls and you
know in New York City or they'd be like
hundreds of kids lines in the hallways
and then my mom was like you know what I
think this is kind of gross I'm not into
you know bringing my child in and she's
like I think if you want to you know
continue acting you should just do it in
school and camp like we've been doing
and no more of the professional stuff
and I'm glad she made that decision for
me she's like when you're 18 you can you
can pursue it professionally and then
when I was 18 I got a lucky break and I
was in a film called kids which friend
of mine had written my best friend at
the time and they cast all
non-professionals and nobody knew will
become of that film and Harvey Weinstein
bought it and Miramax distributed it and
it became like this cult classic so
really I got a lucky break I was
actually doing a lot of music videos as
well like and always surrounding myself
with people who were making films short
films you know had aspirations to make
movies like Spike Jonze even though he
was part of the whole skate culture or
more you know he was making like amazing
skate videos like video days it's a
classic line skateboard video and and he
was a friend of mine so I was always
trying to find some way in doing lots of
music videos and whatnot and then kids
happen and it all went from there
I think when I watched a woman of the
influence when I was around 18 or 19 and
I saw a general uns performance in that
film I just thought she transcended
acting it was something magical on the
screen and she just was that person and
I'm a fan of realism and kasa Fetty
style so which is that that form of
acting is so pure and there's no glamour
or there's no anything I mean she's
obviously just a very beautiful woman
but you know it was just a huge
inspiration to me to see someone give a
performance like that something that I
still aspire towards but you're only as
good as the material you're given or so
I used as an excuse
[Laughter]
I think that you have to you know have a
lot of confidence I think that industry
can really mess with your head and it
has with mine you know I started when I
was 18 19 and it was really hard as as a
woman a young girl and the criticism and
and the judgments people make on you and
it's it's a difficult path to choose I
think you have to be very strong and
have people around you really support
you and because like the body dysmorphic
issues in the industry and what what
happens to young girls I think it's very
sad and disturbing and so I think you
have to really be sure that's what you
want and be sure you can handle it